I'm always trying and sampling new
earphones and headphones to listen to
music and to listen to clips for the
show and cambon sent me their latest
bluetooth headphones the version 4.1 and
I tried them out and I really really
liked them and I'm thrilled that they
have sponsored this video number one my
ears are sort of weirdly shaped in some
way and the flexible ear hooks on these
headphones made it way easier to find a
comfortable position that was actually
stable on my ears and they're also both
waterproof and uh sweat proof and even
though i'm not a big running in the rain
type of guy i do sweat when i run i know
that that is sort of the normal bodily
function for a lot of people and at the
gym or running or cycling or whatever i
really like that they are not impaired
or become slippery or not working
because of wetness and they also worked
really really well with my phone it was
super easy to pair these with my phone
it took just 30 seconds or so and then
they just kind of worked well and the
other thing that I like is the battery
life uh 10 hour battery life on a single
charge on mid volume and how can you
beat that 10 hour battery life believe
me I'm not going to be exercising for 10
hours in a row so at least for me these
the the battery life exceeds the
practical exercise time that I will ever
achieve check out the link in the video
description check out the headphones